hello everyone and welcome back to the
free Day Women's World Church
championship this is game five and for
those of you who are only joining us now
uh do check out my previous video on the
match on game four where I made a pretty
pretty extensive intro about the well
about the entire event it's some six
minutes long so I will not be repeating
that every game of the match do check it
out and only then watch this game so
this game uh late inj has the white
pieces even though I uh said the late
things you had the white piece in the
previous video I messed that up no uh
rating J only has the white pieces in
this game game five and it takes a bit
of a different turn than uh when she
played with the white pieces in game one
Ending game three because here we have
the exact same opening E4 E5 and Knight
to three Knights the C6 uh sorry about
that
uh but in game one and game three the
games that were drawn Bishop to B5 was
played yeah letting you went for the
early Lopez but here she goes for the
Italian game Bishop to C4 and I know
what you guys are wondering is this it
is this the moment we see the Evans
Gambit in a World Series championship
match unfortunately no we have Knights
to F6 the two knights defense and now
Pawn to D3 at the Modern Bishop's
opening with Bishop to C5 castles and
pawn to D6 now uh C3 and Ponte A5 and
we've already had this position in the
world's championship match in 2021 uh
Magnus Carlsen had this position against
the Andy ponishi in game 11 of the
world's championship match where Magnus
played Ponte A5 and it's the game that
Magnus won very nicely with the black
pieces but nipple continued with Rook D1
Rook D1 is the main move uh here in this
configuration but with Bishop to B3 sort
of mixing it up trying to to confuse the
Jew engine uh we have castles and now
rookdale E1 with Bishop act A7 also a
standard move H3 and now Bishop to E6
countering the light Square Bishop on B3
and here there is a game where Knight
beta D2 was played but with Bishop to C2
and it is now as of move 10 that we have
a completely new game so let's see uh
how juven June continues this with Pawn
to H6 again very very standard stuff uh
and the immediate Pawn to D4 uh Jewel
engine captures gladly because now if C
characters then the Knight can come to
B4 but instead Knight captures on the 4
and Just Bishop back to D7 so here uh
Joe Angel wants to move the Knight
probably play C5 and position her Bishop
on this uh long diagonal so Bishop to E3
we have Knight to E5 now moving the
Knight with Knight to D2 and now Pawn to
C5 chasing away the knight from such a
nice Central Square so Knight back to F3
and now Bishop to C6 nicely putting
pressure on that E4 Pawn uh we have a
trade Knight captures on E5 D captures
and now Ponte for stopping further
expansion um uh from black uh via moves
like Ponte B5 we have Queen t7
developing the queen connecting Rooks
and uh late ninja does the same she goes
a queen to E2 with Rook after d8
claiming the only open file on the board
and uh late ninja does the same but not
Rotator D1 Rook e to D1 we have Bishop
to B8 now B6 will be played the strength
in the C5 pawn and the bishop will be
very useful here as of course white
white will definitely want to play a F4
at some point but it's a very dangerous
opening of the position like this
because both of uh them still have the
bishop pair and if the position opens up
wrongly for you you could be in a lot of
trouble so Queen to C4 putting pressure
on that C5 pawn and of course Pawn to B6
we have Pawn to B4 busting open the
position on the queen side a character C
captress and now Bishop to D6 adding
more defense to the C5 Pawn but now Pawn
to B5 and this is what the ratings you
wanted all along at some point she will
play A5 which will either allow her to
create a pass Pawn by capturing on B6 or
by advancing to A6 or uh if B captures
on A5 then the B Pawn will become a past
Pawn so measure back to D7 and now Queen
to C3
uh with a very nice control over the A5
Square we have Bishop to E6 now also
stopping Knight to C4 but you're not
really stopping it as a white will of
course play that Knight the C4 and you
can't really allow this Knight to remain
here it's just a monster so you have to
capture it and you have to give up your
Bishop pair so Bishop captures with
Queen captures and not Knight the E8
re-maneuvering the Knight to C7 Bishop
to B3 nicely putting pressure on F7 so
you also have to worry about that
Knights the C7 and now Queen back to C2
uh we have Knights the E6 now the Knight
can come to D4 it's going to be a
beautiful Square for the Knight and
Bishop to D5 with Rook a to B8 Now The
Rook can no longer remain here Rook 8
the B8 uh uh well just defending the B6
pawn and now Bishop captures an E6 uh
you could play F captures but then you
have two really weak pawns on the E file
that's not really something you want to
do so Queen captures and only now Rook
to D5 preparing to double up on the D
file so root Bishop D7 offering a trade
of rocks and just Rook a to D1 so for
the moment postponing the advancement of
the a pawn but you of course know that
it is coming Rook captures on D5 with
rope captures on D5 and now Rook to A8
which is a very interesting move uh the
problem with Rook to d8 is that you can
advance A5 right away and there is
really nothing black has to show for
this if B captures on A5 you will just
trade here captures captures and capture
the C5 pawn and now your B Pawn is
already almost the Queen the B6 queries
guarded twice even if you advance the
pawns all the way both players can get a
queen but it's just much much easier for
uh White even though black wins with
Czech still after King H2 your Bishop is
hanging you have to play some like Queen
to D7 now you will put pressure even
more pressure on the bishop and now
after let's take a person captures you
get this position okay it's equal
material Bishops are of the same color
but uh it will be late injury who
already have a past Pawn on D5 so maybe
you can defend this uh it's not uh not
uh well not as great uh so Rook the A8
is definitely a better move Bishop to D2
now again keeping around the A5 square
and now King the f8 with Bishop to C3
now also putting pressure on the E5 pawn
and pawn to F6 so no worries there we
have Queen to B3 now you have to again
be worried Rook to d8 check will lose
you the queen so Queen to C8 and now
Queen to C4 we have Queen the E8 and now
Pawn to G3 uh Queen to C8 Zoom Engine
with nothing to do but wait and see what
happens here okay the H3 Pawn has been
weakened so that is hanging a king to G2
and now now Queen to E8 with Ponte H4
Ponte H5 and now Bishop back to D2 We
have rooked the B8 uh Ponte F4 busting
open the position in the center e
captures an F4 and now Bishop captures
on F4 uh grabbing even more space here
so The Rook cannot remain there Rook to
B7 was played and now Queen to E2 a
beautiful uh Square for the queen not
only is it preparing E5 but also she
wants the uh a captured upon an H5 if
the Queen ever moves so G6 strengthening
the H5 Pawn but now you've kind of
weakened the df6 pawn so Pawn to E5
right away definitely makes sense the
black king is uh not as safe as the
white king So Queen to A8 now again you
have to be very careful if you if you if
you play e captures on F6 is just a
force to draw uh because there's a move
like Rook to D7 and the queen is on the
same diagonal as the king and now even
if F captures an E7 check you just move
the king and now you're gonna lose the
Rook on the next move and that's
sufficient for a draw so instead after
between the A8
uh uh after this queen date move such a
move was not played uh there is in fact
only one move that wins you the game and
it's not an easy one to spot so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for late NJ while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
this is a really difficult move to find
you have to put even more stuff on the
exact same diagonal so look at this
diagonal it's really crowded you have to
put even more stuff there Queen to F3 is
the only move that wins this is what 18j
played and now the problem is uh Jew
engine is without a move what do you
play here uh the problem is let's say
you play uh Queen captures on A4 because
if you can capture this Pawn of course
you want to do it you do not want to see
A5 on the board the problem is Rook D2
now you block all of the checks and also
you are threatening The Rook on B7 once
the queen defends or The Rook moves
doesn't really matter Bishop to H6 check
and after King Jade he captures an F6 uh
and okay the bishop is now attacked
after the bishop pulls you can even play
F7 with check and The Rook cannot
capture because the queen would hang on
A8 and now if King to h8 now you just
play Bishop captures and you're down a
piece of course the queen cannot capture
as then The Rook on B7 hang so
everything just falls apart so after
this going to have to remove a dual
engine tried Pawn to F5 keeping the
position close but now this is a
beautiful past Pawn so Rook to D7 again
you cannot capture as the queen would
hang Rook the A7 offering a queen trade
and now a queen captures an A8 here
there there's a much quicker way to win
it's actually Bishop to H6 check and
after the king moves doesn't really
matter where you will play Rook captures
on A7 now the queen has to capture
otherwise you're just down the Rook so
Queen captures and now you play E6 and
that's it you've taken away pretty much
all of the squares from the black king
you can play Queen to C6 check you can
play with some like Queen to C3 to HH
like everything is winning here so after
Rook day seven Queen characters and A8
was played it's uh it's a different path
to Victory but it's still it's still
winning uh Rook captures 98 and now Pawn
to E6 so she prefers to win in an end
game rather than uh with Queens on the
board and now Rook captures on A4 now
the problem is there are a couple of
moves to consider Here pawn to C4 is a
is a very nice one because it kind of
offers counter play for black and we are
going to discuss it for example Rook B7
of course you have to eliminate the B6
pawn bishop to C5 you stop that now
comes Bishop to H6 check King to G8 you
will deliver one more check King h8 Rook
to C7 and now after let's say King to j8
or something because you don't want your
king in the in the corner uh now Bishop
to D2 and it's really hard for black to
find the move uh The Rook can't really
go anywhere the bishop has to remained
here guarding this Pawn uh the bishop is
coming to this diagonal is going to be
really hard for black to defend and if
you try something like Rook here to go
after the pawn then even Rook the C6 you
just defend it and when you play
something uh now A5 is the thread of
course this will be impossible because
the bishop hangs but once you move the
bishop even Bishop to F for now let's
say Pawn to C3 you will play Pawn to A5
captures and pawn to B6 and that's it
there's no
uh there's no defending this position
just a B7 B8 and that's it the B8 square
is covered by the bishop so after this
E6 move we have Rook characters on A4
dual engine tries this instead and now
Rook to B7 going after the B6 Pawn we
have Rook back to A8 and now Rook
capture some B6 now uh lating J has two
uh pass pawns but okay C4 Joe engine
also has one we have Rook to C6 and now
Bishop to d8 interestingly uh Juan Jun
had zero time on the clock here she
basically uh allowed her clock to go
down all the way and then she played the
move on the last second pretty much to
gain more time so it was a very very
intense uh Pawn to B6 we have Rook to A2
with check and now King to F3 we have
rooked the B2 and now Rook the C8 uh the
bishop is pressured so you have to
defend the bishop but there is no good
way to do it Rook the B3 check King to
E2 and now uh what was played is Rook
capture some V6 giving up the bishop on
d8 there's no way to defend it if you
try to defend it Bishop G5 and that's it
there's uh you know uh no way to
actually do it so instead Rook capture
some B6 was played giving up the bishop
for a couple of Pawns Rook captures 78
to check King to E7 and now Rook the C8
going after the C4 pawn and now Rook
captures uh of course an E6 with check
King to B2 and Rook the E4 defending the
pawn so now okay you do have two pawns
for the bishop but of course that's not
gonna last king to C3
uh King F7 and of course Rook captures
on C4 so you know if you trade Rooks of
course it's game over so you have to
keep the Rooks on the board you could
easily resign here but uh you know I
think that you should always uh give
your opponent as many uh possibilities
to make a mistake as you know humanly
possible some would say that it's
disrespectful you should resign I I
don't agree I think that your opponent
if he can win he should prove that he
can win and uh you know just uh play the
game if your opponent wants to play
there's no reason for him to resign uh
so here Rook to C7 with Chuck sorry
about that someone is uh calling me uh I
will answer it later we're keen to have
sex with Bishop to G5 with check King to
E5 and now Rook the E7 with check
finally forcing a trade of Rooks and
that's pretty much it Rook captures
Bishop captures and he was in this
position and move 65 that Jew engine
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so game five goes
to lateing J and she takes the first win
she draws First Blood and now it is up
to uh Jew engine to to retaliate in
order to get the match going in her
favor uh one more uh game will be played
in in her hometown then they are
switching places so you know if um if uh
if there's a time to strike it would
definitely be in game six and game six
has a very special place in the history
of the world chair championships so yeah
we will see what happens there for those
of you who are maybe new to chess and
don't know how this game would play out
well it's a kind of very simple uh I
mean white is up a piece let's say a
king to E4 uh Bishop to G5 and if you
try to snatch a pond and Bishop
therefore and now everything is defended
the king can't touch anything you cannot
push G5 it's nicely defended so
obviously that that can be played and if
you try to just you know hold everything
just uh you know uh say I'm not gonna go
forward but you can't go forward either
it's actually very simple to play this
we're gonna play Bishop to G5 and slowly
uh bring your king up the board of
course the black king will try to
prevent this but we're gonna play King
D3 King D5 King to C for King to E6 now
King to D4 if King to D6 we just kick
him away King goes here we're gonna play
King the C5 King to F6 King to D6 and
the slowly but Charlie push the black
king into the corner at some point black
will have to push upon and if black
prolongs this and doesn't want to do
this then black might even get
checkmated look at this King F7 Bishop
to G5 King to G7 King to E7 King to G8
now we're gonna play Bishop to F6 Force
the black king into the corner King H7
King F7 and after King to H6 you will
play Bishop to E5 sort of wasting a move
and if black still doesn't want to start
giving up pawns Play Place King to H7
now you still made him but only uh you
know not for real because of course
black can still push those pawns and now
after F4 you will capture after G5 you
will capture and now after H4 you will
just deliver a beautiful Pawn to G6
Checkmate so even this is possible uh
but yeah very nicely done by late in J
taking the first win in the tournament
we'll see what happens uh in the match
we'll see what happens in the rest of
the games uh hope to see many more uh
clashes like this uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it very
nicely done again by by Leighton Jay I
would like to thank James Eugene Cashman
Brad Roth Michael Marshall a
bullhessriller.com and Gabriel
Montenegro for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this uh event
uh and checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and everything else that's
happening in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day